les messieurs en ce 24 juin je souhaite
la bienvenue à l'émission bonne fête
nationale
également vous voyez actuellement ces
images en direct les biologistes ce
matin à l'ouverture officielle du pont
samuel de champlain
alors voilà c'est un grand jour donc la
première traversée vient d'être effectué
direction nord donc de la rive sud vers
montréal après quatre ans de travaux un
budget de 4 milliards et demi de dollars
le nouveau pont et samuel de champlain
ouvre donc officiellement il ya beaucoup
de monde qui a travaillé sur ce chantier
là vous le savez à opérer de pointe il
ya eu un maximum de 1600 travailleurs en
tout ce sont 8 millions d'heures
travaillées plus d'un million de boules
ont installé ça vous donne une idée
les travaux qui ont commencé en 2015
termine donc avec six mois de retard
mais voilà c'est ouvert donc je vous le
rappelle seulement direction de montréal
aujourd'hui oui des images en direct qui
nous proviennent donc de la caméra de ma
collègue julie émond qui a fait cette
première traversée julie bonjour on est
toujours sur le pont actuellement là on
est en train d'effectuer cette première
traversée on suit le véhicule du
ministre champagne alors c'est une
voiture hybride conduite par le ministre
françois philippe champagne lui même et
dans ce véhicule qui ouvre le bal
il y a également le ministre des
transports marc garneau d'autres élus
mais surtout deux employés qui ont
participé à la construction de ce pont
d'une belle histoire le père et le fils
qui sont là pour vivre ce moment
historique
jean claude et jesse jourdain donc ils
font partie justement de cette équipe de
2000 travailleurs qui ont participé à la
réalisation à la construction de ce
projet pharaonique alors c'est un moment
historique on est là pour vivre ça avec
vous en dirais qu'il ya quelques
dizaines de véhicules qui nous suivent
qui voulait être parmi les premiers la
traversée le punch à samuel de champlain
vers montréal et parmi ceux ci plusieurs
véhicules électriques justement parce
qu'il y avait un rassemblement organisé
par le club tesla québec et
l'association des propriétaires de
voitures électriques du québec donc ils
se sont donné rendez-vous pour traverser
le pont parmi les premiers vous vous
dire également qu'on a traversé d'abord
au centre la portion du pont à haubans
donc évidemment emblématique qui
deviendra possiblement de signature
emblématique de montréal et dont la
hauteur de la tour du pont à haubans et
plus haute que le mode du stade
olympique fait 170 mètres de hauteur le
pont lui qui fait 3400 mètres de long
dont 3,4 km l'équivalent d'une véritable
piste d'atterrissage à l'aéroport
montréal trudeau alors effectivement les
gens qui se sont rassemblés ce matin
pour vivre ce moment historique avec
nous nous on a une dizaine quelques
dizaines de journalistes de cameramen
des employés aussi du consortium
signature sur le saint laurent qui se
sont rassemblés pour vivre ce moment
avec vous au moment très émotif pour
plusieurs je vous dirais et tout à
l'heure le ministre françois philippe
champagne justement qui tardait à
embarquer en dans son véhicule parce
qu'il voulait prendre le temps de
remercier de serrer les mains et de
saluer l'ensemble des travailleurs qui
étaient encore présents sur le pont afin
justement de les remercier de vie ce
moment avec eux avant d'embarquer au
volant de la voiture hybride
rechargeable est d'ouvrir le bal de nous
conduire comme ça vers montréal /
évidemment le pont le plus achalandé au
pays en vouliez 50 millions de passages
par an 11 millions d'usagers de
transports en commun et 20 milliards de
dollars en échanges commerciaux alors
sépariez après des années d'attenté
après 48 mois de travaux qui avaient
entamé qui avaient été entamées le 19
juin 2015 au coût de 4 milliards et demi
de dollars
et bien finalement on achève à l'instant
cette première traversée du tout nouveau
pont samuel de champlain
effectivement je lis donc vous faites
partie des privilégiés pour aider vos
enfants julie que vous êtes dans les
premières personnes à avoir traversé ce
nouveau pont à samuel de champlain déjà
de leur raconter à mes deux amours un
peu plus tard ce soir ce moment
historique que j'aurais eu la chance de
vivre avec vous en direct matin
parlez-nous de ski